and to be so much fun when the devil
finds his first
love evil shall be released
eve is amazing she's beautiful and she
knows you and accepts you so she should
know that i'm not
serious relationship kind of devil and
yet you were willing to try with chloe
oh we saw how that turned out didn't we
party's over
detective i mean i guess what it really
comes down to
do you want him in your life or not how
is it that sometimes you don't get hurt
and then other times you do
i don't fully understand why i'm only
vulnerable when i'm close to you
it's only a matter of time before the
demons come back to earth
i have to go back my first love was
never eve
was you chloe i love you
don't go goodbye
[Music]
she'll be just fine without me
i'm not good i've been throwing myself
into work and
going out with you at least you guys got
to say goodbye
as far as i'm concerned lucifer can well
he can go to hell me
don't need him
[Music]
hello bad guys
[Applause]
you're here yes i got a bit bored so i
thought it popped back
up lucifer is
acting different down there time is
different
i was in hell for thousands of years a
few things might have changed
lucifer 2.0 you're back
great
how could you go home without me i'm not
lucifer
lucifer told me he had a twin brother
nice to meet you i'm michael
i am not gonna break lucifer's life i'm
gonna take it
he is stronger than you think
what do you truly desire
welcome home how do you like the mess i
[Music]
made
for now i'm going to stick to police
work and avoid anything god related
hilarious
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is gonna be my new lucifer season five
trailer video they've also been talking
about what's going on with season six
episodes so i'll be sure to explain all
that stuff if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos the season is coming
the same weekend that the dc fandom
comic con event is happening in a couple
weeks too
so there'll be a lot of big dc movie and
tv show trailers coming in the next
couple of weeks
the big thing with this trailer is
obviously just the big reveal that
michael his twin brother is going to be
the main villain of season six
the way that they're doing the season is
a little bit different too they're
actually breaking it in half
but there are 16 episodes instead of 10
so it's like a super sized season
they're only releasing the first half of
the season in a couple weeks the first
eight episodes and then the second half
i'm assuming is either gonna release at
the end of this year or sometime early
next year
they didn't say whether or not season
six would also be super sized or if it'd
be like the normal ten
episodes like season four was the way
the showrunner talks about
michael though he just talks about tom
ellis going crazy playing different
versions of himself so they said they
didn't want to shy away from that so
that's why the big michael twist reveal
is in this trailer but you have michael
showing up at the beginning of the
season because lucifer is still trapped
being the king of hell trying to take
everything that lucifer has
he's probably been watching him this
whole time like all the other archangels
and the people in heaven have been
watching lucifer being really pissed off
about what he's been doing on planet
earth
we've seen angels in the past get really
upset about the freedom that he enjoys
even though he's a fallen angel and was
banished down to hell
most of the angels still have a lot of
petty rivalries between them like
families siblings fight which of the
children does the parent favor the most
and it's just
implied through the course of the series
that god always favored lucifer the most
which is why his betrayal
stung so hard it also helps explain some
of the big twists with chloe's character
and the way her powers work and the way
he set that up for lucifer
but as the trailer implies not too much
time goes by before
team lucifer finds out that it's really
not lucifer it's actually michael
pretending to be him it seems like
mastakeen is the one that figures it out
first like wait a minute lucifer said he
had a twin brother
if you're having trouble telling them
apart there are a couple of key
differences in the way they look in the
way that they talk
so the main differences between lucifer
and michael are that lucifer has a
british accent
and white wings like lucifer
lightbringer and michael has an american
accent which does sound kind of weird
coming out of tom ellis after listening
to him with that british
accent for all these seasons and he also
has black wings so you see black wings a
couple times during the trailers that's
just the key to let you know that that's
michael doing all those things in those
scenes
but it seems like when he shows up at
the beginning of the trailer in the
first couple of episodes like they're
implying
michael is posing as lucifer imitating
his british accent
but the way they're playing it is that
it's tom ellis imitating himself
as lucifer you have to remember that
this is tom ellis playing both of these
characters so he's the dude
playing a dude pretending to be another
dude post
all your tropic thunder robert downey jr
memes
the way they're talking about season six
though is that it is supposed to be
their final season
but what happened was is that when they
were planning all the season five
episodes
originally they thought that season 5
episode 16 was going to be the series
finale so they worked in all these super
sized endings for all the different
characters
subplots and storylines into that final
episode
like think about lord of the rings
return of the king with the many
different endings that that movie had
they had a version of that going on in
the season five finale
so when they got renewed for season six
they just took a lot of the stuff
from the original season five finale and
turned that into the beginning of their
season six storyline
but they didn't really give anything
away about what happens in the season
five finale obviously
but if you've been following the series
for a long time lucifer and chloe's
character arcs you can kind of guess
where they're headed with their season 6
storyline his whole big internal
conflict in previous seasons was all
about his identity through the way his
powers his wings his devil face worked
like that was a big thing during season
four my devil faces back
so at the end of season four he's
telling chloe that he has to go back to
hell because he's no longer running away
from his responsibilities he's a little
more confident
in his identity but he feels like he
can't be on earth with her anymore
because he's supposed to be the king of
hell and if he's not there to do his
ordained job there's always going to be
some demon
or some villain to escape and cause some
world-ending problem
so it's like it's a job that only he can
do so he's going back it's a little bit
like
thor and the mcu and the avengers movies
thor spends most of his movies wanting
to be king
thinking that he wants to be king but
then running away from his
responsibilities every chance he gets
but if you're thinking about a happy
ending for these characters or a version
of a happy ending i think part of the
idea with the final two seasons will be
him finding the proper balance between
his life in hell and his role in the
grander cosmic sense
and still being able to have a
relationship with chloe
you can theorycraft all you want about
her becoming the next queen of hell with
him at the end of season six
but i know there are a lot of questions
about how chloe's powers work because
michael is showing up people are
wondering if her powers will also work
on michael if he's lucifer's twin
the whole thing is that when she's in
close proximity to him he becomes mortal
again and the show is just suggested
that it's because god
wanted to do lucifer a solid he had a
menideal bless a baby that baby wound up
being chloe so she had this very
cosmically miraculous birth
and her passive ability makes immortal
beings like lucifer mortal again
because she's been blessed by god when
they're near her
so the theory is that the lucifer could
potentially have a version of a happy
ending with her a family with her like
his endgame would be living a normal
life
but the thing is is that her ability
doesn't work on all immortal beings but
the big wrinkle now is michael being his
twin
there was a recent exchange on twitter
with the showrunner and one of the ew
writers
and some of the tweets made people think
that chloe's ability to weaken lucifer
would also work on michael too and that
might somehow be part of the key to
defeating michael
this season but that's just speculation
right now we don't know if her abilities
work on michael
and none of the trailer footage really
gives any of that away there are a
couple big easter eggs during the
trailer you probably noticed like this
seems like a pretty obvious 2001 space
odyssey reference
this scene seems like it's ripped right
out of the shining with the little kid
riding the bike through the hallway
i know everybody saw lucifer during
crisis on infinite earths and now
they're wondering if he's going to be
crossing over with other future dc shows
right now we don't know if constantine
from the dc tv universe will be the same
constantine of the justice league dark
hbo series that they're working on i
wouldn't hold my breath on that too much
i think that's going to be a little more
connected to what's happening with the
dc movies and they're still kind of
separating dc movies and dc tv shows
even though they tried to canonize all
that stuff in the crisis on infinite
earth's post-credits scene
the way they explained the lucifer tv
show inside the dc
tv arrowverse multiverse is that it's on
earth
666 and that was just meant to be a very
obvious joke about the devil so that's
them just winking at that so it is
always possible if tom ellis does come
back after season six to do more
lucifer's stuff he comes back into the
arrowverse tv shows
hopefully we'll get more news about that
at the dc fandom comic con in a couple
weeks
there'll be a bunch of big trailers
they're doing a panel for the batman
movie with robert pattinson for all the
other big dc movies
zack snyder said they're dropping a new
justice league snyder cut trailer so as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all those videos
when i post them and
of course i will do a couple videos for
lucifer season 5.
but while you wait for everything click
here for my umbrella academy season 2
breakdown and season 3 teaser and click
here for that new trailer video for the
boys season 2
also coming in a couple weeks thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]